the latest entry in Nintendo's
charmingly offbeat life sim series
Animal Crossing New Horizons is out now
it's great
it has wholesome villages delicious
fruit and you can hang out with your
buddies it's a charming and relaxing
game what you may not know is that the
beloved series actually comes from one
of Nintendo's worst commercial failures
ever Animal Crossing made its debut on
the world stage in nearly 20 years ago
with 2002 s Animal Crossing for the
Gamecube however the series actually
began life on the Nintendo 64
the very first Animal Crossing was known
in Japan as door boot tsunemori or
animal forest and was the brainchild of
two Nintendo designers Katsuya Eguchi
and Hisashi Nogami while neither of
these two lads may have the same name
recognition as Shigeru Miyamoto or Eiji
Aonuma they still had a hand in creating
some of Nintendo's most beloved tiles ug
directed starfox and wave race 64 while
no gummy worked as a character designer
on Yoshi's Island and Mario Kart 64 he
also went on to produce splatoon
according to Iguchi Animal Crossing was
originally envisioned for the 64dd the
ill-fated disk drive peripheral for the
Nintendo 64 it began life as an n64 DD
project he explained in an interview we
came up with the concept of a game where
you hang out and do stuff with a bunch
of people in a single field then one by
one we started coming up with more ideas
and Animal Crossing is really just a
collection of all those different
strands wouldn't you know it it turns
out Animal Crossing was actually the
first strand game
sorry Kojima the 64dd attached to the
n64 underside and expanded the system's
functionality with a range of additional
hardware features the peripheral boasted
a drive for rewritable floppy disks an
internal clock and even offered limited
Internet connectivity Nintendo said that
these features would inspire new kinds
of games and genres and its design is
definitely seemed energized by the
possibilities it opened up the 64 d DS
real time clock in particular was
instrumental to the Animal Crossing idea
in fact the entire game was pretty much
built around it just like in the real
world days and seasons in Animal
Crossing would pass by according to the
calendar so your village would be
blanketed in snow during the winter
months and cherry blossoms would bloom
during the spring intern different types
of fish and insects would emerge
depending on the time of the year and
holidays would be celebrated in the game
as they occurred in real life this
created the sense that Animal Crossing
was a small living world marching along
inside your console even when you
weren't actively playing it despite the
64 Dedes potential however the
peripheral was plagued by setbacks
Nintendo originally intended to launch
it in 1997 a year after the n64 itself
but the company encountered numerous
hurdles during its development
so it was repeatedly delayed when the
64dd did finally hit the market late in
1999 it was near the end of the n64
lifetime and only a small handful of
games supporter the accessory was
unceremoniously discontinued a little
over a year after it launched with the
64dd being a non-starter animal forest
was eventually released on the standard
n64 cartridge but the developers still
found ways to incorporate features that
were inspired by the 64dd without
utilizing the hardware itself since the
n64 itself didn't have an internal clock
Nintendo included a battery backed one
in the animal forest cartridge allowing
the game to track the date and time
likewise instead of storing additional
data on the 64 Dedes floppy disks the
game made use of a controller pack a
memory card that plugged into the back
of the n64 controller these workarounds
allowed the developers to release animal
forests on the base n64 hardware without
sacrificing the game's most distinctive
features animal forest launched in Japan
in April 2001 making it one of the final
first-party titles to hit the system
before it was supplied by the GameCube
later that year this unfortunate timing
undoubtedly hampered the game sales and
the n64 version wasn't released outside
of Japan the title would however get a
second lease on life when it was ported
to the GameCube that December in turn
those new totally cubular system would
prove to be a more fitting home for the
game as many of the features the 64dd
offered including a real-time clock were
built right into the hardware Animal
Crossing made its debut in the US the
following year after some extensive
localization changes the game eventually
went on to sell more than 2 million
copies worldwide an impressive number
for what was at the time a new and
unconventional franchise
however the titles follow-up Animal
Crossing wild world for the DS really
propelled the series to worldwide
popularity wild world moved more than 11
million copies and each successive
mainline installment likewise has become
a multi-million seller with new leaf
shifting more than 12 million copies on
the 3ds each of these games builds upon
the original animal forest foundation
with new features activities and
customization options but the core
appeal of the series remains its
leisurely real-time pace and that has
its roots in the 64dd the peripheral may
have failed to live up to Nintendo's
expectations but it definitely inspired
a new kind of game thanks for watching
this brief history on the interesting
origins of Animal Crossing if you're
playing new horizons make sure to check
out our guides we've got a bunch of tips
for when you start and when you continue
to progress while you're there make sure
to hit the subscribe button we're all
still playing Animal Crossing and loving
it so we'll keep you updated on new
discoveries
[Music]